الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله
استقيموا اعتدلوا استو سو صف سد
الخلل
الله
اكبر
سبحان
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اقترب للناس حسابهم وهم في غفله
معرضون ما ياتيهم من ذكر من ربهم محدث الا
استمعوه وهم
يلعبون
لاهيه
قلوبهم واسر النجوى الذين ظلموا هل هذا
الا بشر
مثلكم افتاتون السحر وانتم
تبصرون قال ربي يعلم القول في
السماء وهو السميع
العليم قال ربي يعلم القول في
السماء والارض وهو السميع
العليم بل قالوا اضغاث
احلام بل افتراه بل هو
شاعر فليات
بايه كما ارسل
الاولون ما امنت قبلهم من قريه
اهلكناها افهم
يؤمنون ومن ارسلنا قبلك الا رجالا نوحي
اليهم فاسالوا اهل الذكر ان كنتم لا
تعلمون وما جعلناهم جسدا لا ياكلون الطعام
وما كانوا
خالدين ثم
صدقناهم الوعد
فانجيناهم
فانجيناهم ومن
نشاء واهلكنا المسرفين
لقد
انزلنا اليكم كتابا فيه ذكركم افلا تعقلون
وكم قصمنا من قريه كانت
ظالمه
وانشان بعدها قوما
اخرين فلما احسوا باسنا اذا هم منها
يركضون لا تركضوا وارجعوا الى ما اترفتم
فيه ومساكن م لعلكم
تسالون قالوا يا
ويلنا انا كنا
ظالمين فما زالت تلك دعواهم حتى جعلناهم
حصيدا
خامدين وما خلقنا
السماء والارض وما بينهما لاعبي
لو اردنا ان نتخذ لهو
لاتخذنا لو اردنا ان نتخذ لهو
لاتخذناه من
لدنا
لدنا ان كنا
فاعلين بل نقذف بالحق على الباط فيدمغه
فاذا هو
زاهق ولكم الويل
مما
تصفون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وله من في السماوات والارض ومن عنده
لا
يستكبرون لا يستكبرون عن عبادته ولا
يستحسرون
يسبحون الليل والنهار لا
يفترون ام اتخذوا
الهه من الارض هم
ينشرون لو كان فيهما الهه الا الله
لفسدتا فسبحان الله رب العرش عما
يصفون لا يسال عما يفعل وهم
يسالون ام اتخذوا من دونه الهه قل هاتوا
برهانكم هذا ذكر من معي وذكر من
قبليه بل اكثرهم لا يعلمون الحق فهم
معرضون وما ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول الا
نوحي
اليه الا نوحي اليه انه لا اله الا انا
فاعبدون وما ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول الا
نوحي
اليه الا نوحي اليه انه لا اله الا انا
فاعبدون وقالوا اتخذ الرحمن
ولدا سبحانه بل
عباد
مكرمون لا
يسبقونه بالقول وهم بامره
يعملون يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما
خلفهم ولا يشفع
الا لمن
ارتضاه
وهم من خشيته
مشفقون ومن يقل منهم اني اله من دونه فذلك
نجزيه
جهنم كذلك نجزي
الظالمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم
الله
[Silence]
الله الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏st
ا
[Silence]
‏ja
بس
[Silence]
ا
استقيم اعتدل
استو
الله
اكبر اعوذ بالله
مني الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
اولم ير الذين كفروا ان السماوات والارض
كانتا رتقا ففتقناهما
وجعلنا من
الماء كل شيء حي افلا
يؤمنون وجعلنا في الارض رواسي ان تميد بهم
وجعلنا فيها فجاجا سبلا لعلهم
يهتدون وجعلنا
السماء سقفا
محفوظا وهم عن اياتها
معرضون وهو الذي خلق الليل
والنهار والشمس
والقمر كل في فلك
يسبحون وما جعلنا لبشر من قبلك الخلد
افان مت فهم
الخالدون كل نفس
ذائقه
الموت
ونبلوكم بالشر والخير فتنه والينا
ترجعون واذا راك الذين كفروا ان
يتخذونك الا
هزوا اهذا ال الذي يذكر الهتكم وهم بذكر
الرحمن هم
كافرون خلق
الانسان من
عجل ساريكم اياتي فلا
تستعجلون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين لو يعلم الذين كفروا حين لا يكفون
عن وج
حين لا
يكفون حين لا يكفون عن وجوههم النار ولا
عن
ظهورهم ولا هم
ينصرون بل تاتيهم
بغته فتبهتهم فلا يستطيعون
ردها فلا يستطيعون ردها ولا هم
ينظرون ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فحاق
بالذين سخروا
منهم فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون قل من
يكلؤكم بالليل
والنهار من
الرحمن بل هم عن ذكر ربهم
رضون ام لهم
الهه تمنعهم من
دوننا فلا لا يستطيعون نصر انفسهم ولا هم
منا
يصحبون بل متعنا هؤلاء
واباءهم بل متعنا
هؤلاء
واباء هم حتى طال عليهم العمر افلا يرون
انا ناتي الارض
ننقصها من
اطرافها افهم
الغالبون قل انما
انذركم بالوحي ولا يسمع الصم الدعاء اذا
ما
ينذرون ولئن مس ستهم نفحه من عذاب ربك
ليقولون
ليقولون يا ويلنا انا كنا
ظالمين ونضع الموازين القسط ليوم
القيامه فلا تظلم نفس
شيئا وان كان مثقال حبه من ردل اتينا بها
وكفى اتينا بها وكفى بنا
حاسبين ولقد اتينا موسى وهارون الفرقان
وضياء
وذكرا وذكرا
للمتقين الذين هم الذين يخشون
ربهم بالغيب وهم من سعه
مشفقون وهذا ذكر مبارك
انزلناه
افانتم له
منكرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتينا ابراهيم رشده من قبل وكنا
به
عالمين اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما هذه
التماثيل التي انتم لها
عاكفون قالوا وجدنا
اباءنا لها
عابدين قال لقد كنتم انتم
واباؤكم في ضلال
مبين قالوا اجئتنا بالحق ام انت
اللاعبين قال بل ربكم رب السماوات والارض
الذي
فطرهم وانا وانا على ذلكم من
الشاهدين وت الله
لاكيدن اصنامكم بعد ان تولوا
مدبرين فجعلهم جذاذا الا كبيرا م لعلهم
اليه
يرجعون قالوا من فعل هذا بالهتنا
انه لمن
الظالمين قالوا سمعنا فت
يذكرهم يقال له
ابراهيم قالوا فاتوا به على اعين الناس
لعلهم
يشهدون قالوا انت فعلت هذا بالهتنا يا
ابراهيم قال بل فعله كبيرهم هذا
فاسالوه
فاسالوه ان كانوا
ينطقون فرجعوا الى
انفسهم فقالوا انكم انتم
الظالمون ثم
ثم نكسوا على
رؤوسهم لقد علمت ما
هؤلاء
ينطقون قال فتعب من دون الله ما لا
ينفعكم شيئا ولا
يضركم اف لكم ولما تعبدون من دون
الله
افلا
تعقلون قالوا حرقوه وانصروا الهتكم ان
كنتم
فاعلين قلنا يا نار كوني بردا وسلاما على
ابراهيم وارادوا به كيدا
فجعلناهم
الاخسرين
ونجيناه ولوط
الى ونجيناه ولوطا الى الارض التي باركنا
فيها
للعالمين ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب نافله
وكلا جعلنا
صالحين
وجعلناهم
ائمه يهدون بامرنا واوحينا اليهم
واوحينا اليهم فعل الخيرات واقام الصلاه
وايتاء
الزكاه وكانوا لنا
عابدين ولوطا اتيناه
حكما
وعلما
ونجيناه من القريه التي كانت تعمل
الخبائث ان انهم كانوا قوم سوء
فاسقين
وادخلناه في
رحمتنا انه من
الصالحين ونوحا اذ نادى من قبل فاستجبنا
له فاستجبنا له
فنجيناه واهله من الكرب
العظيم ونصرناه من من القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا
انهم قوم سوء
فاغرقناهم اجمعين
و انهم كانوا قوم سوء
فاغرقناهم
اجمعين وداوود وسليمان اذ يحكمان في الحرث
اذ نفشت فيه غنم
القوم
وكنا لحكمهم
شاهدين
ففهمناها سليمان وكلا اتينا حكما
وعلما وسخرنا مع داوود الجبال يسبحن
والطير
وكنا
فاعلين وعلمناه صنعه لبوس لكم لتحصنكم من
باسكم فهل انتم
شاكرون ولسليمان الريح
عاصفه تجري بامره الى الارض التي باركنا
فيها
وكنا بكل شيء
عالمين ومن الشياطين من يغوصون له ويعملون
عم ويعملون
عملا دون ذلك
وكننا لهم
حافظين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
استقيم
واست
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وايوب اذ نادى ربه اني مسني الضر
وانت ارحم
الراحمين فاستجبنا له فكشفنا ما به من ضر
واتيناه اهله
ومثلهم
معهم
واتيناه اهله ومثلهم معهم رحمه من عندنا
وذكرى
للعابدين
واسماعيل ادريس وذا الكفل كل من
الصابرين
وادخلنا في رحمتنا
انهم من
الصالحين وذ النون اذ ذهب
مغاضبا فظن ان لن نقدر عليه فنادى في
الظلمات ان
لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين
فاستجبنا له
ونجيناه من الغم وكذلك ننجي
المؤمنين وزكريا اذ نادى ربه رب لا تذرني
فردا وانت خير
الوارثين فاستجبنا له و وبنا له يحيى
واصلحنا له
زوجه انهم كانوا يسارعون في الخيرات
ويدعوننا رغبا ورهبا وكانوا لنا
خاشعين والتي احصنت فرجها فنفخنا فيها من
روحنا
وجعلناها وابنها ايه
للعالمين ان هذه
امتكم
امه
واحده وانا ربكم
فاعبدون وتقطعوا امرهم
بينهم كل الينا
راجعون فمن يعمل من الصالحات وهو مؤمن فلا
كفران لسعي
وانا له
كاتبون وحرام على قريه
اهلكناها انهم لا
يرجعون حتى اذا فتحت ياجوج وماجوج وهم من
كل حدب
ينسلون واقترب الوعد الحق فاذا هي شاخصه
ابصار الذين كفروا يا ويلنا قد كنا في
غفله من هذا بل كنا
ظالمين انكم وما تعبدون من دون الله حصب
جهنم انتم لها
واردون لو كان
هؤلاء الهه ما وردوها وكل فيها
خالدون لهم فيها زفير وهم فيها لا
يسمعون ان الذين سبقت لهم م الحسنى
اولئك عنها
مبعدون لا يسمعون حسيسها وهم فيما اشتهت
ان انفسهم
خالدون لا يحزنهم الفزع الاكبر
وتتلقاهم
الملائكه هذا يومكم الذي كنتم
توعدون يوم نطوي
السماء كطي السجل
للكتب كما بدانا اول خلق نعيده وعد علينا
انا كنا
فاعلين ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من بعد الذكر
ان الارض يرثها عبادي
الصالحون ان في هذا لبلاغا لقوم
عابدين وما ارسلناك الا رحمه
للعالمين قل انما يوحى الي
انما الهكم اله
واحد فهل انتم
مسلمون فان تولوا فقل
اذنتكم على
سواء وان ادري اقريب ام بعيد ما
توعدون انه يعلم الجه من
القول ويعلم ما
تكتمون وان ادري لعله فتنه لكم ومتاع الى
حين قال رب احكم
بالحق وربنا
الرحمن المستعان على ما
تصفون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم ان زلزله
الساعه شيء
عظيم يوم ترونها تذهل كل مرضعه عما ارضعت
وتضع كل ذات حمل
حملها وترى الناس سكارى وما هم بسكارى
ولكن عذاب الله شديد
ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير علم
ويتبع كل
شيطان
مريد كتب عليه انه من تول فانه يضله
ويهديه الى عذاب
السعير يا ايها الناس ان كنتم في ريب من
البعث فانا
خلقناكم من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم من
علقه ثم من مضغه
مخلقه وغير مخلقه لنبين لكم لنبين لكم
ونقر في الارحام ما
نشاء الى
مسمى ثم نخرجكم طفلا ثم لتبلغوا
اشدكم
ومنكم من يتوفى
ومنكم من يرد الى ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم
من بعد علم
شيئا وترى الارض
هامده فاذا انز نا عليها
الماء اهتزت وربت
وانبتت من كل زوج
بهيج ذلك بان الله هو الحق
وانه يحيي الموتى وانه على كل شيء
قدير وان الساعه اتيه لا ريب في
وان الله يبعث من في
القبور ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير
علم ولا هدى ولا كتاب منير ثاني عطفه ليضل
عن سبيل الله له في الدنيا خزي
الحريق ذلك بما قدمت يداك وان الله ليس
بظلام
للعبيد ومن الناس من يعبد الله على حرف
فان اصابه خير
اطمان به وان اصابته فتنه انقلب على وجهه
خسر الدن
والاخره ذلك هو الخسران
المبين يدعوا من دون الله ما لا يضره وما
لا
ينفعه ذلك هو الضلال
البعيد يدعوا لمن ضره اقرب من نفعه لبئس
المولى ولبئس
العشي
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
سلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ا
‏s بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعين
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شر انفسنا ومن
سيات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مض ومن يضلل فلا
دي واشهد ان محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وعلى
اتبارك
وسلم
عليه
[Silence]
ولاميه
الله
خ ‏it
was sent
لام ver in today's day we feel quite
ashamed
if the family of the girl asks for the
boy and we make it a t today that has to
be a girl a boy family that has to go
ask for a girls it doesn't have to be if
you see that there is a good match
[Silence]
‏things
come
things
[Silence]
لام
الله
سبال of from
from and that one circle and we go anse
around the times to do
cation the black cube
is
عليه
[Silence]
الهلاميه
was
from
‏onlyone
smalling there
recently
there can
the
‏because
any
all
[Silence]
الله
‏there
all
[Silence]
يهل
الله
علسلام
[Silence]
that عليه الصلاه
والسلام
‏and people
back
truth
‏was
firstone
covering been times
after
silvery
onlyou
[Silence]
عنيه
‏areil
because
blackone and one point
ofe has a and that ched over the years
there some clots some white clot there
some green clots there was never a
singular col available for as it ex
today this idea that we have always was
a black cube it was never a black cube
to begin with
‏those of the
cube
حاله
صلى الله
[Silence]
علس
اله الا الله محمد رسول الله ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا عذاب جنم وقنا
عذا المحيا والمات وقنا عذا فتنه المسيح
الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك السميع اليم وتب
علينا يا مولانا الرحيم صلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحه اجمين برحتك الرامين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللين
استقيم التلاوه ان شاء الله نفرس رك الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ان الله يفعل ما
يريد من كان يظن ان لن ينصره الله في
الدنيا والاخره فل ي دد بسبب الى
السماء ثم ليقطع
فلينظر فلينظر هل يذهبن كيده ما
يغيظ وكذلك
انزلناه ايات
بينات وان الله يهدي من
يريد ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا والص
صابئين
والنصارى والمجوس والذين اشركوا ان الله
يفصل بينهم يوم
القيامه ان الله على كل شيء
شهيد الم تر ان الله يسجد له من في
السماوات ومن في الارض والشمس والقمر
والنجوم والجبال والشجر
والدواب وكثير من
الناس وكثير حق عليه
العذاب ومن يهن الله فما له من مكرم ان
الله يفعل ما
يشاء الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر هذان خصمان اختصموا في ربهم فالذين
كفروا قطعت لهم ثياب من نار يصب من فوق
رؤوسهم
الحميم يصهر به ما في بطونهم
والجنود ولهم مقامع من
حديد كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها من غم
اعيدوا فيها وذوقوا عذاب
الحريق ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار يحلون
فيها يحلون فيها من اساور من ذهب ولؤلؤا
ولباسهم فيها حرير وهدوا الى الطيب من
القول وهدوا الى صراط
الحميد ان الذين كفروا ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والمسجد الحرام الذي جعلنا
للناس
سواء العاكف فيه
والباد ومن يرد فيه
بالحاد بظلم نذقه من عذاب
اليم واذ بوانا
لابراهيم مكان البيت الا تشرك بي شيئا
وطهر بيتي
للطائفين
القائمين والركع
السجود
واذن في الناس بالحج ياتوك رجالا وعلى كل
ضامر ياتين من كل فج
عميق ليشهدوا منافع لهم ويذكروا اسم الله
في ايام
معلومات على ما رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام فكلوا منها واطعموا
البائس
الفقير ثم ليقضوا تفثهم وليوفوا نذورهم
وليطوفوا
بالبيت
العتيق ذلك ومن يعظم حرمات الله فهو خير
له عند
ربه احلت لكم الانعام الا ما يتلى عليكم
فاجتنبوا الرجس من الاوثان واجتنبوا قول
الزور
واجتنبوا قول الزور
حنفاء لله غير مشركين به ومن يشرك بالله
فكانما خر من
السماء فتخ يطفه الطير او تهوي به الريح
في مكان
سحيق ذلك ومن يعظم
شعائر الله فانها من تقوى
القلوب لكم فيها منافع الى اجل
مسما ثم محلها الى البيت
العتيق ولكل
امه جعلنا من سكن ليذكر اسم الله على ما
رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام فاله اله
واحد فله اسلموا وبشر
المخبتين الذين اذا ذكر الله وجلت قلوبهم
والصابرين على ما اصابهم والمقيم
الصلاه والمقيم الصلاه ومما
رزقناهم
ينفقون والبدن جعلناها لكم من
شعائر الله لكم فيها خير فاذكروا اسم الله
عليها
صواف فاذا وجبت جنوبها فكلوا منها واطعموا
القانع
والمعتر كذلك
سخرناها لكم لعلكم
تشكرون لن ينال الله لحومها ولا
دماؤها ولكن يناله التقوى
منكم كذلك سخرها لكم يكبر الله على ما
هداكم وبشر
المحسنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله يدافع عن الذين امنوا ان
الله لا يحب كل
خوان
كفور اذن للذين يقاتلون
بانهم ظلموا وان الله على نصرهم
لقدير الذين اخرجوا من ديارهم بغير حق الا
ان يقولوا ربنا
الله ولولا دفع الله الناس بعضهم ببعض
لهدمت صوامع وبيع
وصلوات
ومساجد ومساجد يذكر فيها اسم الله
كثيرا ولينصرن
الله من
ينصره ان الله لقوي
عزيز الذين ان
مكناهم في الارض اقاموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه وامروا بالمعروف ونهوا عن
المنكر ولله عاقبه
الامور وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح
وعاد
وثمود وقوم ابراهيم وقوم لوط واصحاب مدين
وكذب موسى فامليت
للكافرين ثم اخذتهم فكيف كان
نكير
فكاي من قريه
اهلكناها وهي
ظالمه فهي خاويه على عروشها وبئر
معطله وقصر
مشيد افلم يسيروا في الارض فتكون لهم قلوب
يعقلون بها او اذان يسمعون بها فانها لا
تعمى
الابصار ولكن تعمى القلوب التي في
الصدور
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ويستعجلونك بالعذاب ولن يخلف الله وعده
وان يوما عند ربك كالف سنه مما تعد
وكاي من قريه امليت لها ثم اخذتها والي
امليت لها وهي
ظالمه ثم اخذتها والي
المصير قل يا ايها الناس انما انا لكم
نذير
مبين فالذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
مغفره ورزق كريم والذين سعوا في اياتنا
معاجزين
اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم وما ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول ولا
نبي الا اذا تمنى القى الشيطان في
امنيته فينسخ الله ما يلق الشيطان ثم يحكم
الله اياته والله عليم
حكيم ليجعل ما يلقي الشيطان فتنه للذين في
قلوبهم
مرض وان الظالمين لفي شقاق
بعيد والقاسيه قلوبهم وان الظالمين لفي
شقاق بعيد وليعلم الذين اوتوا العلم انه
الحق من ربك فيؤمنوا به فتخبت له
قلوبهم وان الله لهادي الذين امنوا الى
صراط
مستقيم ولا يزال الذين كفروا في مريه منه
حتى تاتيهم الساعه بغته او ياتيهم عذاب
يوم
عقيم الملك يومئذ لله يحكم بينهم فالذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات في جنات
النعيم والذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا
فاولئك لهم عذاب مهين والذين هاجروا في
سبيل الله ثم قتلوا او ماتوا
ليرزقنهم الله رزقا حسنا وان الله لهو خير
الرازقين
ليدخلنهم مدخلا
يرضونه وان الله لحليم
غفور
لعل
وان الله لعليم حليم ذلك بان الله يولج
الليل في النهار ويولج
النهار في الليل وان الله سميع
بصير ذلك ومن عاقب بمثل ما عوقب به ثم
ثم ثم بغي عليه
لينصرنه الله ان الله لعفو غفور ذلك بان
الله يولج الليل في النهار ويولج النهار
في الليل وان الله سميع
بصير ذلك بان الله هو الحق وان ما يدعون
من دونه هو الباطل
وان الله هو العلي
الكبير الم تر ان الله انزل من
السماء
ماء فتصبح الارض
مخضره ان الله لطيف خبير له ما في
السماوات وما في الارض وان الله لهو الغني
الحميد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الم تر ان الله سخر لكم ما في الارض
والفلك تجري في البحر بامره ويمسك
السماء ان تقع على الارض الا باذنه ان
الله بالناس لرؤوف
رحيم وهو الذي احياكم ثم يميتكم ثم يحييكم
ان الانسان
لكفور لكل امه جعلنا من سكنهم ناسكوه فلا
ينازعنك في الامر وادع الى ربك انك لعلى
هدى
مستقيم وان جادلوك فقل الله اعلم بما
تعملون الله يحكم بينكم يوم القيامه فيما
كنتم فيه
تختلفون الم تعلم ان الله يعلم ما في
السماء والارض ان ذلك في
كتاب ان ذلك على الله
يسير ويعبدون من دون الله ما ما لم ينزل
به سلطانا وما ليس لهم به علم وما
للظالمين من
نصير واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا
بينات تعرف في وجوه الذين كفروا المنكر
يكادون يسطون بالذين يتلون عليهم
اياتنا
قل افان ابئ بشر من ذلكم النار وعدها الله
الذين كفروا وبئس
المصير يا ايها الناس ضرب مثل فاستمعوا له
ان الذين تدعون من دون الله لن يخلقوا
ذبابا ولو اجتمعوا له وان يسلبهم الذباب
شيئا لا يستنقذوه منه ضعف الطالب
والمطلوب ما قدر الله حق قدره ان الله
لقوي
عزيز الله يصطفي من
الملائكه رسلا ومن
الناس ان الله سميع بصير يعلم ما بين
ايديهم وما خلفهم والى الله ترجع
الامور يا ايها الذين امنوا اركعوا
واسجدوا واعبدوا ربكم وافعلوا الخير لعلكم
تفلحون الله
اكبر
الله
وجاهدوا في الله حق جهاده هو اجتباكم وما
جعل عليكم في الدين من
حرج مله ابيكم ابراهيم
هو
سماكم المسلمين من قبل وفي هذا ليكون
الرسول شهيدا عليكم وتكونوا
شهداء على
الناس فاقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
واعتصموا بالله هو مولاكم فنعم المولى
ونعم ال
النصير الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اللهم
ا صلاه الوتر
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والشمس
وضحاها والقمر اذا تلاها
والنهار اذا
جلاها والليل اذا
يغشاها
والسماء وما بناها والارض وما
طحاها ونفس وما سواها فالهمها فجورها
وتقواها قد افلح
من زكاها وقد خاب
من
دساها كذبت م بطغواها
اذ بعث اشقاها فقال لهم رسول الله ناقه
الله
وسقياها فكذبوه فعقروها
فدمدم عليهم ربهم
بذنبهم
فسواها ولا يخاف
عقباها الله
اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين انا
انزلناه في ليله القدر وما ادراك ما ليله
القدر ليله القدر خير من الف شهر تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن
ربهم من كل امر سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له
كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه في
الدنيا الاخره اللهم انا نسالك العفو
والعافيه في الدنيا
والاخره اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه
في الدنيا
والاخره اللهم حبب الينا الايمان وزينه في
قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار اللهم بلغنا
ليله القدر وتقبل منا بفضلك يا اكرم
الاكرمين واجعلنا من عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم يا ذا الجلال والاكرام يا
ذا الفضل
والانعام نسالك ان تمن على اخواننا
المستضعفين بالنصر والتمكين
اللهم كن لهم عونا ونصيرا اللهم كن لهم
عونا
ونصيرا اللهم ك لهم عونا
ونصيرا اللهم عليك بالمتجر
والمستكبرين اللهم اهلكهم و اللهم اقتلهم
بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تبق منهم احدا اللهم
اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تذر منهم
احدا
انهم لا
يعجزونك وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
شيخ الله
يحفظك